Good morning my friends! I'm back today with a cool little trick
that traces back to my childhood.
Now a lot of you have probably seen this done before,
I'm doing this video for those of you who haven't.
It's really simple , it's really fun, and honestly it's something you can go try right now!
All your gonna need for this experiment is: a fork, a spoon, a couple of matches or some toothpicks and
some kind of a glass  or a container that you can set them on.
When you got your fork and your spoon, we simply want to
push them together, taking the tip of our spoon, and pushing it into the tines of the fork.
What we're looking for here are the two outer tines of the fork on the backside of the spoon and the inner tines right on the center
What this does essentially is turn your fork and spoon into a little pendulum that you can balance on your finger.
But here is where it gets really cool!
Take your matchstick and push the back end of it through the center tines of the fork, about an eight of an inch.
Now if you center it just right and hold this by the head of the match you can see the whole
thing balances. And if you set this down on the edge of a container or a glass, it almost
seems to do the impossible. It balances in place. The reason this trick works is because we're manipulating the center of gravity. The mass
in the handles of the fork and the spoon are actually heavier than they are at the heads.
This point of the matchstick is called the center of gravity, Its the exact perfect point where the whole system can be balanced
and because the majority of the weight is actually below the center of gravity it makes the whole system very stable
which means you can jiggle it a little bit and it won't fall off.
Now take your fork and your spoon pull out your matchstick and this time we are gonna put it in top tine  here
Now you'll find that in this configuration when we set it down on the edge of our cup our fulcrum point has shifted to about the center point of the matchstick
So we got half of the matchstick on the one side and half of the matchstick on the other.
So now here is the question
If we light the end of this matchstick on fire how much of the wood will have to be burned to tip the balance making the fork and spoon fall off?
Go ahead and make your predictions in the comments right now.
Will the fork and spoon fall off the second we light the off or do you thing it will actually hang on until the flame burns the wood pass the edge of the glass?
Lets light it up to find out
3.....2.....1
Ignition
Alright we got our flame.
You can see the matchstick is starting to burn here.
The system hasn't moved. It's not even shaking.
We've consumed about a quarter of the matchstick.
We're coming up on the edge.
And here is the moment of truth.
Flame is a little past the edge,
and it just went out.
Did you guys see that? The flame was burning and then as soon as it hit the edge of the glass it spontaneously went out.
It like extinguished itself
Look at the black charred match head here and we just tap that with another matchstick
we can actually break it right off.
Look at that.
And that's the exact fulcrum point of the system
Perfectly balanced
Lets try that again and see if we can get it to burn any further
I'm gonna tilt this one slightly uphill so it burns a little faster.
It's approaching the edge of the glass with good speed.
And there it is...
And the flame dies out.
Every single time
Every single time guys the flame hits the edge of the glass the flame goes out.
Let's try one more time just to be sure.
I'm actually gonna stand over here just to make sure that my breath isn't interfering.
The flame is past the edge...
and...
Yep,
every single time.
So guys this is really interesting three times we lit these off and all three times the flame traveled to the edge of the glass,
sometimes beyond but before the thing actually fell off the flame went out.
Why do you thing that is?
Its very interesting very curious isn't it?
And here is something else that's cool: if you take another matchstick you can actually balance this right on the tip.
So that's it guys.
Extremely cool experiment with gravity and center of gravity that you can go try right now.
And if you have already tried this trick before go try it again or share it with a friend.
It's just as much fun the second time.
Thanks for joining me for this experiment guys, and I'll be looking for ya on the next one.
Talk to you then!
My bad, i just dropped the spoon and the fork and just broke my glass. Cost of doing business.
Bye bye Martini Glass you've served us well.
Hey guys, quick reminder that limited time King of Random t-shirts are now on sale.
Click the link in the top of the description or visit randomgear.com. See you there.